il a voulu son Balou merci merci la vie
ça fait un mois et demi que je me bats
pour le retrouver quoi de toute façon je
lâcherai jamais parce que c'est ma
famille quoi c'est ma famille qu'on m'a
arraché
[Musique]
produit motion
je crois pas j'y crois pas je j'attends
de voir
[Musique]
le policier encore en opération là il
est avec quatre policiers ils ont repéré
le gars ils ont bayour et en fait un des
deux voleurs c'est sauvé ils sont en
train d'essai de l'attraper il me
rappelle tout de suite mais en tout cas
Bayou et retrouver c'est un truc de fou
c'est la fin d'un cauchemar de 50 jours
j'en peux
plus tellement heureux j'aime tellement
la vie je remercie tellement les gens
c'est un truc de ouf
en fait c'est un truc de dingue comme
quoi cette mobilisation sur les réseaux
sociaux nous a énormément aidé c'est une
dame qui prenait son RER la ligne H et
qui a vu notre chien donc avec deux
individus à la gare de Sarcelles
Saint-Brice décembre qui les a pris en
photo et qui nous a envoyé directement
nous ce qu'on a fait on avait la police
sur place les dernières infos que j'ai
c'est
qu'ici il y a
tenter son retour et en fait il les a
repéré donc il sait pas il est parti en
courant et apparemment ils l'ont perdu
dans un immeuble donc là ils sont encore
en train d'essayer de le toper mais
on va rejoindre les policiers qui sont
en train d'essayer d'interpeller le
voleur en fait qui sont en planque
carrément dans un dans l'immeuble dans
un hall d'immeuble donc ils nous ont
envoyé leur localisation pour qu'on
aille retrouver Bayou et eux ils
espèrent en attendant le temps qu'on
arrive que le l'individu sort de sa
cachette parce qu'il est parti s'enfuir
dans un des appartements apparemment
donc
on a trop hâte d'arriver et c'est pas
encore enlevé la peur de
je sais pas je
veux juste le voir quoi
c'est interminable cette attente et là
pour le coup je suis un peu convaincu
que c'est un vol d'opportunisme parce
que le chien il l'a pas vendu il la
garde avec lui donc on se demande en
fait si c'était pas juste un coup de
cœur qu'il a eu en tout cas il a pas mal
traité faut pas rentrer dans la cité
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
il y a deux minutes mais merci mon pote
merci en fait j'ai fait tout le tour de
la ville et je vois Bayou ici pendant
que je marchais là mais c'est pas
possible c'est c'est énorme je
m'approche et je vois quatre mecs les
mecs viennent vraiment lui dire bonjour
monsieur vous allez bien il me tiennent
genre vous êtes la police c'est bon on a
retrouvé Bayou on attend juste que le
mec arrive
du haut là ils sont pas eu le temps
c'est une connaissance
[Musique]
vous venez monsieur
merci et donc là en fait je suis obligé
de ça risque de prendre du temps je suis
obligé de porter plainte contre personne
dénommée mais ouais il m'a fait la fête
et tout et moi il est perturbé on sent
que c'est plus trop où il est
il est il a pris trois ou quatre
kilomètres
salut salut
[Musique]
d'une histoire de longue haleine qui
nous a empêché de dormir pendant
longtemps qui nous a empêché carrément
de vivre même pendant longtemps et
là c'est ça c'est un ça se finit bien
c'est génial c'est génial
il n'y a pas de mots en fait
ça nous conforte dans l'idée de
continuer
[Musique]
je remercie tellement la vie je remercie
tellement les gens franchement
même celui qui l'a volé je le remercie
de bien l'avoir traité de apparemment de
bien l'avoir nourri il a pris 3 kg là
et ça aussi faut que ça serve il faut
vraiment que ça sorte l'idée c'est que
le combat ça reste pas ici nous tout
être mobilisation elle a fini par payer
on a retrouvé le chien mais il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas aidés
comme nous qui sont passés qui ont été
abandonnés
aussi donc l'idée c'est d'utiliser aussi
toute cette mobilisation des soutien
pour aider ceux qui n'ont pas forcément
une autre chance
rien n'aurait été possible sans autant
de mobilisation c'est vraiment se
reportage sur brut qui a été la clé de
tout quoi parce que 3 millions de vues
en trois jours ça fait qu'ensuite tous
les médias me téléphone aujourd'hui j'ai
eu Europe 1 au téléphone c'est à vous
et voilà c'est grâce à vous quoi c'est
grâce à tout à toute la mobilisation au
fait que que les gens soient émus
tu es content de retrouver ton frère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]